Trascrizione: Ilaria Merrina
Revisore: Piero Cavallo
Invisibile.
Inutile.
Indifferente.
Guardalo, è solo.
Solo.
Mi fai schifo.
Mi faccio schifo.
Non ha senso esistere.
Vi faccio una semplice domanda:
quante persone si reputano introverse
in quest’aula?
Proviamo ad alzare la mano.
Mi aggiungo anch’io alla lista.
Non abbiate paura.
Ok, abbiamo un bel gruppetto.
Che poi si può essere introversi
in modi diversi.
Nessuno è mai 100% introverso
o 100% estroverso.
Ma ovviamente c’è chi tende
più da una parte o più dall’altra.
Tutti in certe situazioni
vorremmo nasconderci, scappare,
andare in camera nostra,
chiuderci dentro
e stare con noi stessi.
In altri momenti, invece, vorremmo aprirci
socializzare, condividere
e connettere con gli altri.
Se voi non vi reputate introversi,
avrete sicuramente un amico,
un compagno di classe,
un conoscente, un familiare
che ha questo tipo di personalità.
Essere introversi non è un problema.
Anzi, penso sia un modo bellissimo
di vivere la vita.
Ma se quella persona si sente sola,
inutile, invisibile,
allora questo è un problema.
Ed è un caso generale, un caso specifico.
Nella scena di prima,
avete visto quanto le parole degli altri
e il silenzio può renderci invisibili.
Ma spesso siamo noi stessi
a sottovalutarci,
a pensare di non poter fare di più.
E la società in questo non ci aiuta.
Anzi, pensate a quante volte vediamo
nei telegiornali, nei social network,
per strada, anche di violenza,
di discriminazione.
Quando una persona sembra essere diversa,
viene automaticamente esclusa dal gruppo.
È normale una cosa del genere?
Perché accade questo?
Come posso io, come individuo,
cambiare tutto ciò?
O è forse il mondo un posto troppo tossico
perché troppo sensibile?
Vogliamo tutti un mondo
più unito, più giusto.
L’utopia di un mondo
senza discriminazioni.
Sogniamo collettivamente
una società migliore.
Sogniamo, ma l’Italia non va avanti,
l’Italia è in rovina.
Non c'è futuro, non c'è speranza.
Quante volte sentiamo questi lamenti,
questi commenti?
Ma effettivamente quante sono le persone
che si impegnano per cambiare tutto ciò?
Quante sono le persone che vogliono
dedicare le loro energie e il loro tempo
per costruire qualcosa di concreto?
È ridicolo quanto qualcuno venga messo
su un piedistallo come se fosse un eroe
soltanto per essersi impegnato
nella collettività.
Dovrebbe essere qualcosa di normale.
Quante sono le persone disposte a ciò?
La risposta è:
molte.
Molte effettivamente sono le persone
che decidono di sfruttare
tutto il loro potere personale
per fare qualcosa di buono.
E non dobbiamo andare lontani.
Anche qui in Italia, a Senigallia,
nella nostra stessa scuola,
nelle associazioni di volontariato
negli ospedali, in centri di ascolto,
di assistenza, di recupero
tra docenti, madri, padri,
attivisti di tutti i giorni,
persone che decidono
di non essere indifferenti
in un mondo che sembra quasi violento.
Basti pensare
a quanto sono importanti i volontari
in qualsiasi associazione di volontariato.
Perché senza di loro,
il mondo cadrebbe nell’indifferenza.
Dove non vi è posto
per chi ha veramente bisogno.
Sono persone
che decidono di combattere
nelle piccole
e grandi battaglie quotidiane,
per non ricreare mai più
la scena che avete visto prima.
E quindi il mio appello é questo:
possiamo tutti essere volontari quotidiani
finché, utopicamente, un giorno,
non sarà più qualcosa di speciale
ma la normalità per tutti.
Nessuno è invisibile.
Grazie.
(Applausi)